[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Looking to create
an event-driven app?
Give me a minute and I'll show
you how, using Cloud Functions.
Cloud Functions is an
event-driven, serverless
compute platform with scales
automatically based on load.
And you're only billed
while the code is running,
so if your function is
idle, the cost is zero.
It's easy to set up.
Just write your logic in any
of the supporting languages
and trigger it
via HTTP requests.
File uploads to Cloud
Storage, Events, and Pub/Sub,
or Firebase.
It offers built-in security at
role and at per-function level.
You can also observe and
diagnose your applications
using the Operations tools.
Cloud Functions acts
as a building block.
You can build real-time
data processing apps,
like bringing in IoT
device data for analysis,
calling machine learning
APIs to extract information
and images, texts, or videos
as soon as the file is uploaded
to Cloud Storage, creating
conversational experiences
with Dialogflow, and
even creating serverless
back ends using Firebase
and third-party apps.
Next time you're looking to
create an event-driven app,
take a minute and look
at Cloud Functions.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/functions.